Fallon is apologizing to his sta
after accusations by former
and current
staffers of a toxic work environ
at The Tonight Show in a Rolling
Some of the claims involve the h
drinking at work, and a high tur
due to mental health issues.
I want to bring in the reporter
who broke this story, Krystie Le
So Krystie,
your report has detailed
these examples of these outburst
can you lay out for us what you
Yes.
So from the two current and 14 f
who I spoke to on the record,
they said that a lot of their mi
So the alleged behavior from Fal
and so on and so forth.
They spoke to me a lot about,
you know, these
what they called
Jimmy's good days, that they cal
And his mood kind of dictating,
you know, the vibe of the whole
you know,
stopping at
crew members,
not having a lot of patience wit
I mean,
what that's what toxicity is, yo
and the bad that comes with that
And then how that over the years
health as well.
Yeah.
What happened today in
that apology that he gave to his
I spoke to two current staff mem
call with Jimmy and the current
They told me that Jimmy apologiz
He said he was sorry.
He said that Chris Miller is goi
to be the showrunner for the res
you know, his time at The Tonigh
And yeah, I mean, he apologized.
He he didn't really deny anythin
And he apologized for, you know,
I don't know what the apology wa
He didn't get specific in it.
But, you know, the people who
I didn't speak to who were on th
said that they felt like it was
a genuine place.
And is NBC responding as well?
NBC responded on the record in o
They also did not deny things th
They did acknowledge that in the
employees had made complaints to
and that they took proper action
So they did respond in that way.
So did anybody in the
you know,
I'm sure dozens of conversations
that you had with current and fo
Did anybody speak up to defend
working at The Tonight Show with
So I've reached out to in total
current and former staffers.
One employee who works for NBC,
got back to me and they emailed
there and that they've worked wi
for years in different capacitie
They declined to talk on the pho
and they weren't available to ch
but that was the one person who
And many people did also say, yo
They think he's a very talented
Those are definitely things peop
That's
really interesting and seems to
volumes really after all of this
Krystie Lee Yandoli thank you ve